-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The Tonight Show"!
Thank you for watching.
Thank you for being here.
Guys, it's that time of year.
Tomorrow is SantaCon...
[ Audience laughs, groans ]
...here in New York City.
[ Laughter ]
You already know what it is.
Yeah, at SantaCon, thousands of
people will dress up as Santa
and pack the streets
for an all-day bar crawl.
So, before you go to bed,
make sure you put out
a plate of Advil
and a tall glass of Pedialyte.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, happy SantaCon.
To everyone in their 20s,
have fun.
To everyone in their 30s,
it's getting kind of sad.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, get this,
according to a new survey,
30% of Americans
have injured themselves
during holiday-related
activities.
While the other 70% are the ones
filming it for TikTok.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, 30% get injured.
Who knew climbing a ladder
and hanging lights
on an icy gutter
could be dangerous?
[ Laughter ]
Actually, the most common injury
is spraining your face
from fake smiling
after opening a present.
[ Laughter ]
"It's a Slanket.
Oh, cool.
I -- I'll google it,
and I love it."
Speaking of the holidays,
this weekend
First Lady Jill Biden
will give a tour
of the White House
holiday decorations
for an HGTV Christmas special.
Yeah, and after that, stay tuned
for Melania's
decoration special,
"The Nightmare
Before Christmas."
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news.
I saw a new poll
that said President Biden's
approval rating
is now up to 46%.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
46%, that's pretty much
the blood-alcohol content
of everyone at SantaCon.
[ Laughter ]
I like that we're cool
with 46% for a president,
but if a restaurant
had 2 1/2 stars on Yelp,
we'd call
the health department.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
A top adviser
to Senator Bernie Sanders
said that if Biden
doesn't run in 2024,
Sanders will give it
a hard look.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, people weren't sure
about him
the last two elections,
but maybe they'll vote for him
now that he's more mature.
[ Laughter ]
Some more big news
from Washington.
Today, Senator Kyrsten Sinema
announced
that she's leaving
the Democratic Party
and registering
as an Independent.
It's good timing, 'cause
nothing says the holiday season
like leaving a party early.
Right?
[ Laughter ]
Well, listen to this.
I heard that if Putin loses
the war in Ukraine,
he's going to flee
to South America.
Yeah, and he has his disguise
all planned out.
He's gonna wear a shirt.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
[ Rim shot ]
Some business news --
Apple has a new iMessage feature
that will alert both users
if they were being spied on
by a state-sponsored attacker.
Yeah, it's never good seeing
"North Korea
has entered the chat."
And you go...
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
I read that the
Miss Universe Pageant is moving
from broadcast TV to streaming
on the Roku Channel.
Yep, and now the winner
of the talent portion
is whoever can find
the Roku Channel.
[ Laughter ]
When asked how
they felt about it,
a representative for the pageant
said, "World peace."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, last night in L.A.,
there was a big
video-game award show
called The Game Awards, okay?
And they got a pretty huge actor
to present.
Take a look at this.
-Please join me in welcoming
to the Game Awards, Al Pacino.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But, uh, I -- I -- I --
I'm -- It's hard for me
to see the teleprompter.
[ Laughter ]
I don't play
a whole lot of video games.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
-Wha-- Wha-- What?
[ Laughter continues ]
-It was Pacino's
most challenging role yet,
"guy who wants to be here."
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if he
played "Super Mario Bros.,"
but he definitely
ate a mushroom.
[ Laughter ]
Once the mushrooms
wear off, he's like,
"Say hello
to my little friend."
[ Mario shrinking sound ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
I do space work.
-Yeah, wow, space work,
very good.
-Hey, this is going viral.
A man, who was out kayaking,
saw a great white shark.
Yeah, and then, when he asked
his friend what he should do,
his friend had
a very interesting response.
Watch this.
-Dude, Danny.
-Yeah.
-What do I do?
Holy [bleep]
-Film it.
-Holy [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-Honestly, at that point,
what else can you really do,
I guess?
He was like, "Uh, now slap it
with a tortilla!"
[ Laughter ]
"Slap the shark
with a tortilla!"
And finally, a puppy was found
after he escaped from his home
in Manhattan and swam across
the Hudson River to New Jersey.
He swam all the way
to New Jersey
just to get away from SantaCon.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show.
Let's go write some
thank-you notes.
Come with me.
-[ Rapping indistinctly ]
♪♪
♪ I spit some riffs,
they're so savage ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What a show we have
for you tonight.
Miley Cyrus is here
tonight, everybody.
-Oh, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
I think I've had enough.
-You're tired of it?
-I think I've had
enough of the beard.
[ Audience groans ]
-No.
-Yeah.
-What?
-I'm getting rid of the beard.
[ Audience shouting ]
-I just decided.
-No!
-Tonight?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Wow.
They're like animals!
-I've got a shaver.
Should we do it tonight?
Can we ask Miley Cyrus if she
wants to shave my beard tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
She would do it.
I'm ready -- I'm ready to get
rid of it, I think.
-You're sick of it.
-I just --
I think it's too much beard.
It's overtaking me.
[ Laughter ]
-You think that you're becoming
more beard than Jimmy.
-No, no joke, people all --
all people want to know about
is the beard.
That's -- This is more --
this is getting more attention
than the show.
It's taking away from the show.
-Well, your beard's
getting a show on Roku, right?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, of course.
Yeah, it's got
its own show on Roku, but...
I -- I grew my beard,
and then Quest grew his beard,
then Tariq grew a beard,
then Stro grew a beard.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
Mark.
Everyone in The Roots
has a beard.
-I said no.
I said, "Just say no."
[ Light laughter ]
-You said that?
-Yeah.
I think, yeah, I think --
'cause, you know, it's enough.
-That's it.
You're done.
-Let's see if Miley will do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Want to do it?
I'll do it.
If she's down,
I'll do it tonight.
I don't care, yeah, I love it.
Guys, today's Friday,
and that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and of course I send out
thank-you notes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I was running a bit behind.
So I thought if you guys
wouldn't mind just --
thank you -- I'd like to write
us some --
James, give us some thank-you
note writing music, please.
♪♪
-He has, like,
a goatee just to mock you.
-Yeah, that's kind
of weird to me.
-He didn't even grow
a whole beard.
-[ Laughs ]
-Wow.
-He doesn't have a beard,
really.
It's more of a, uh --
-It's like a goatee
or a Van Dyke.
-It's like a --
[ Laughter ]
It's like a Mitch Miller-type
of vibe.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughs ]
Or a Van Dyke mustache.
-I mean, I can shave this thing.
I did it, I -- Tariq dared me,
I proved it,
I, you know, La Schmoove.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-I don't got nothing to prove.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't edit that.
Don't edit.
-Man, La Schmoove, man.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you, SantaCon,
for looking like
a "Where's Waldo?"
for sober people.
It's like, "Oh, that person.
That person."
[ Applause ]
Thank you, car reindeer set,
for letting everyone on the road
know that you're a lot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let 'em go.
-Just let 'em go.
Let 'em pass you,
let 'em go the other way,
we don't care, just -- yeah,
they've got something going on.
-They got some issues.
[ Imitating car horn,
scatting "La Cucaracha" ]
-Thank you, Harry and Meghan's
new Netflix documentary,
for getting King Charles to sign
up for Peacock.
Ooh, well, there you go.
That's one way to do it.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Thank you, Spotify Wrapped,
for reminding me
of that one night in May I fell
asleep with whale sounds
on repeat.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Whale sounds?
That's my song?
-What?
-You listened to it
for 1,500 minutes.
-1,500 minutes of whale sounds.
Fart noises are number two.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, opening one window
while driving,
for making me feel like
I'm getting an MRI
in the middle of a tornado.
It's like...
-[ Warbling sounds ]
[ Laughs ]
-Wub-wub-wub-wub-wub-wub-wub-
wub-wub-wub...
[ Singing "Chariots of Fire" ]
-Make it better, faster,
stronger.
-How's everything else going?
[ Laughter ]
How's that beard coming?
-It's throwing
the whole game off.
-Yeah.
-Beard's messing
with your brain.
-It's just making me look, yeah.
-I mean, you never had it,
you know, really properly
sort of, you know...
-Wow.
-[Crowd] Oh!
-Wow. Properly sort of?
-I mean, you know...
-Properly sorted -- that --
-You never had it, like,
you know.
Like --
-Like what you have?
-I mean, you could never
have what I have.
-I don't --
-But, I mean --
-I don't live in the woods
for eight years.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbals crash ]
You never had it, like,
you know, connecting and --
-It looks like you're wearing
a disguise.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a Brawny paper towel.
-Yeah, I mean, at least
you can see who it is.
-What did Steve say yesterday?
Your beard looks like
a COVID mask
with a hole cut out in it?
[ Laughter ]
-He's right!
He's got a point.
[ Laughter ]
It's too thick.
-Yeah, no.
-[ Laughs ]
-Thank you,
office Christmas parties
for having the rule --
liquor before beer,
you're in the clear.
Beer before liquor,
you'll see HR quicker.
There you go, okay.
There you go.
-"I said that?
I said that?"
♪♪
-Thank you, Aaron Judge,
or as your family now calls you,
Santa.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our thank-you notes.
Hey, guys.
We have exactly six shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It is time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Six days left ♪
-That's right, every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a whopper of a Christmas sweater
from the Countdown to Christmas
Cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since there are six shows left,
let's open door number 6.
-Ready?
-I'm ready for this.
-I'm always ready.
-I'm ready.
-I appreciate this.
-Good. Ready?
[ Drum roll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I like this one. I like this.
Flowy.
Flowy, subtle.
I like this a lot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone,
look at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drum roll,
please?
[ Drum roll ]
2-8-2!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! Come on, bud.
♪♪
Yes, yes, yes!
Nice to see you, bud.
How are you?
Nice to see you, pal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Ken Kavanaugh
from Austin, Texas.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Austin, Texas.
We love it.
It does get a little chilly out
there in Texas
every now and then.
-Yes, it does.
-Yeah.
Do you have anything like this
that you could --
[ Light laughter ]
-No, I do not.
-No, you don't.
Would you like to try it on
right now for everyone?
Speaking about keeping it weird,
we've got to keep it weird,
Austin.
♪♪
Hang on. Here you go.
-Yeah!
[ Cheering ]
-Oh, yeah.
That's perfect.
Oh! Oh, this is perfect.
Are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is --
that's what you wear out.
This is fantastic.
One more time,
give him a round of applause.
Stick around.
We'll be right back.
Congratulations.
Happy holidays.